good
morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
thursday welcome to the back latter half
of the week it is exciting to be here it
is humbling to be here and it's really
even more humbling to be here with my
sister
my co-host my best friend
jackie hey jax how you doing
me
me
mei
i'm doing good after that introduction
my day is made
and i'm just feeling so grateful and i
mean the question on everyone's lips no
one cares about me today
everyone wants to know about bunny girl
please tell us about your evenings they
also i thought you were going to say
they want to know about the queen you
know we have developing news this
morning
with the positive like i'm a good news
first kind of person yeah um it really
is hard to do any other stories other
than queenie
yeah
but let's start with the good news of
the day which is that claudius off bunny
girl last night leah michelle's second
night performing as fanny bryce at the
august wilson theater
and she has come with a full report for
us
so
like there are really no words first of
all you know i don't think anyone was
questioning whether she was going to
kill the singing she's such an amazing
singer those are such hard songs to sing
especially the ones that we know like
don't right now my parade is a very big
song you have to be an extremely like
wide range like me you know i can only
the best singers can sing it it's true
though it's like it's like a star
spangled banner type it's a very
difficult song to sing not anyone with a
good voice can sing it um and the
singing was so
spectacular
it was so
moving like it was incredible
but i think a lot of where people were
concerned or like you know
just anticipating to see
how leah played fanny because and by the
way i had never seen funny girl the
movie or the show i honestly wasn't even
sure what the plot was i had like a
vague idea like she wanted to be famous
really she wants to be a star yeah like
relatable
um but i didn't really know like what
fanny was like and fanny is like this
ball she's a lunatic like she's [ __ ]
crazy singing dancing you know very
physical she's very very funny obviously
the show is about her she's a funny girl
um and so you know prior to seeing the
show last night would i have considered
leah michelle to be a particularly funny
person or a particularly comedic actress
no
but i was so impressed with how [ __ ]
funny she was like it was not real when
i tell you i was cackling like
every five minutes which i don't really
like laugh at broadway shows like i'm
just i'm i'm not an easy person to make
laugh like some people can laugh at
anything i am not one of those people
she was so
funny hysterical like her physical
comedy the way she delivered her lines
like this show i think was an hour long
because people were just laughing so
much like and they would wait for the pl
the laughs to stop before continuing on
to the next line everyone was great but
leah like
the way i have
a whole new respect for her
outside of her musical singing voice is
just not what i expected like she was
from the minute she started she was so
[ __ ] funny like just hysterical there
were so many moments also
the woman who plays her mom tova feldcha
oh my god she was
incredible like i was cackling from her
and i mean i guess if i had sat down and
thought about it i would have come to
the realization like it's an extremely
jewish show
um but i just did like the thought never
crossed my mind it's just like oh
barbara's jewish but like there's all
about her neighborhood in brooklyn so
much of the humor they were like using
yiddish words like hamish like it is
that a yiddish word yeah i think so yeah
um it was so like steeped in our culture
that it was so enjoyable um
it was incredible the guy who played mr
arnstein is so hot i just like wasn't
expecting like such a hot piece of ass
to walk onto stage and there was a scene
without his shirt on so it was funny
because when you looked around the
audience like it was literally jewish
girls
and gay guys
and honestly after seeing the show that
makes complete sense
and
first of all like i know if i walk into
a room full of young jewish women like
it's literally a room of toasters you
know yeah what i didn't expect was how
many gay male toasters we have like it
was overwhelming to say the least to
meet so many and like that just made me
feel so good like yes like i feel like
you know gays have a really high bar
especially when it comes to podcasting
and for them to enjoy this show like
there's really like there's no greater
honor jackie
i really thought we had like because i
could see it when i go to my shows
there's like you know one or two
gay male toasters um but we are like i
think we're huge in the gay community
like that's what i learned in addition
to all the other things i learned last
night not to make everything about us
but i just thought that was really
interesting oh i love that for us so it
was a very toasty crowd you're saying oh
beyond and so i was really like waiting
for so many celebs to show up but i
guess like the one you were the celeb no
literally it was podcasters anonymous
because the only other famous person i
saw was bowen yang who also has a
podcast and he was there with his
podcast host so
um it was podcaster's night out piano
and honestly he was probably better than
the first night i think it was really
sienna comedians night out i would say
that bowen yang is a comedian before
he's a podcaster well pete well he's a
really really like strong following on
his podcast les culturists does they
hosted an award show like how we're
literally always saying we want to do
that they did the culturistas awards how
long have they been doing it for i don't
know but i had seen them like popping up
on my peripheral podcast radar for a
little while now and i think they're
extremely popular
that's awesome
yeah so it was it was a good night for
podcasters podcasters in the wild
podcasters in the while jackie was so
good i need you to see it like
but i i have to be you know also honest
and and it's important that before i say
this like i also say like i don't love
broadway shows that's just what i was
gonna ask you
so i don't love broadway shows i just
find them to be kind of torturous like
there's lines for the bathroom line for
basic human needs like get a pee sorry
you have to wait 45 minutes you need a
water sorry you gotta wait 45 minutes
sweating too bad the theater's hot like
there's a lot of things about the
broadway experience that i don't
particularly like and you know it's
never gonna be my first second third
fourth or fifth option for a night out
it's just not um so having said that
while i did enjoy the show immensely
like there was that element of like i'd
literally rather be anywhere else um
especially because the second act was
slow
it was slow and it was about 30 minutes
too long the show i think is in total
like three hours and that's just like a
little long for me yeah i was going to
ask you if you got
a little bored at any point just because
of course broadway shows
are long yeah
and you're still you i was yawning like
towards the end but then like so
literally like the whole time you're
waiting for don't read on my parade and
then at the scene before i literally had
like chills at this and i literally
cried like not to be a weenie um i cried
twice when she was the first song when
she was like i am the
greatest star
like it was so leah it was so fanny like
it was so rachel berry it was just too
much
and then um right before intermission is
don't rain on my parade and she comes
out in this red outfit and she's at the
train station so everyone knows because
in the movie like she's on the boat you
know she misses the train whatever
um
so you like know it's coming and the
anticipation it's like it's too much
and she just does don't ruin my parade
and it's spectacular just
spectacular but before that there's like
another less popular verse of don't rate
on my parade with then american beauty
knows and so she does that little quick
verse before the intermission then she
does
don't write down my parade in full
before the intermission and then in the
last scene she does that original verse
again with ten american beauty toes and
it's so like full circle like you just
have chills like the song is threaded
throughout the whole show
and it was just spectacular like it
first of all i don't know how everyone
there on the stage wasn't dying it was
three hours of just nonstop and that's
broadway i think broadway is literally
one of the most difficult jobs ever like
it's just endless hours of singing
dancing sweating moving remembering your
lines so it was really um i was in awe
of everyone and everyone was incredible
and i really was just kept thinking like
i could not imagine
beanie feldstein doing this job um i
also really could not imagine jane lynch
as the mom
i don't know if jane i didn't realize
that tovah took over for jane yeah and i
don't know if jane lynch is jewish um
but you need like tova felchia who's
clearly jewish i don't even need to look
it up
she had really had that like old jewish
mom what are you kidding sing for like i
just can't see an accent the accent i'm
really rigid about accents especially if
it's like one of my people like i'm
gonna think it's fake but leah really
nailed the like brooklyn it was jewish
accent it was really really good and her
mom was so
[ __ ] funny and her mom is like this
gaggle of ladies which are just like
classic ladies like just bragging about
the fact that their daughter's married
it was just
it was spectacular like if you have a
chance to go see leah
see it it's really it's a once in a
lifetime experience like i was really
like really in the moment feeling like
very
honored and privileged to have gotten
the tickets like it was it was a
fabulous night out in new york and then
we walked out of the theater me and ben
walked eighth avenue got a cab it was
like so new york this lady chain smoking
cigarettes started a fight with ben and
ben is like
okay so what happened was we got to the
corner and ben stuck his arm out for a
cab and we didn't see that there was a
woman like standing right behind ben
so she was waiting for a cab it was like
a cigarette hanging out of her mouth i
don't know why that's an important
detail i just need you to know what kind
of type of woman she was she was like
she had a smoker's voice and she was
[ __ ] nasty
and she's like excuse me
and ben's like oh i'm sorry i didn't see
you like we would never steal a cab from
especially from an older woman like we
just we genuinely did not see her
and it was just a true accident and
she's like going have some etiquette
like screaming at us and ben is going
back and forth with her i'm like ben
this woman is obviously mentally ill
like why are you fighting with an old
lady in the street
and i'm saying this in front of the
woman i'm like ben this woman is clearly
unwell like what are you starting a
fight with her for and i'm just like i'm
unintentionally gassing her up too
yeah and then two cabs came and it was
honestly just like a perfect night in
new york
that's so beautiful i'm so happy for you
incredible in crayon five stars five
keys you know who else i'm happy for
the cast and crew of the show who
haven't changed since the original show
and now like there's this whole new
excitement and fanfare joie de vivre for
everyone who's coming i'm sure the
people on stage it's like a whole new
show
and
it's like a whole new they're taking on
a whole new life with it so i'm excited
for them no there was like a palpable
energy like the second they made the
announcement about phones and then like
the composer like stuck her head out and
did this like little introduction music
um
there was an electricity in the room
that like you really can't you have to
be there to describe it i was like
screaming i was like i meant everyone's
screaming like
like it was it was a lot like it was a
lot of energy um and of course like we
were quaking because in the first act
she's you know flirting with mr arnstein
and
she says she's like i don't read a lot
of books
and the audience erupted and i had heard
that that happened the first night the
second night it jackie they it was
literally like a 45 second delay like
people were just at first it was like a
slow cackle and then everyone started
brian was like why are people laughing
i'm like because she can't read
and like it was like this slow rumble
and mr arnstein was supposed to say
something and like he literally couldn't
because people were cackling um
and what was so great about it is like
it's really like a comedic show it's
like
it's you think you when you think of
funny girl you think of the music but
it's really like all about comedic
timing and the way that like the
audience played a part in
adding to the jokes a little bit like
it was
i don't feel like there'll ever be a
show where they do it the exact same
because there was just like
it was literally like a live comedy show
yeah it was crazy it was so good like me
and margo and ben and brian like we were
dying would you see it again
i would but i would leave after the
first act
okay only because like i literally got
home when i woke up today i feel like i
ran the marathon i'm like oh my god it's
saturday thank god and my alarm went off
i was like what
it was it was exhausting like literally
yeah imagine how she feels no i know i
could and she did a matinee that day
also the wednesdays there's two o'clock
and at eight o'clock and she had done
one the night before i'm telling you
like people who are on broadway have my
utmost respect it is the hardest job i
just really hope that we can find a way
for her to qualify for the tony because
what you told me is not right
so um somebody did let me know that uh
recently the tony's made a small
amendment that like a replacement
there's like maybe another category
where like a replacement can be eligible
okay all hope is not lost
okay that's good and she beyond deserves
it like she didn't crack once you know
it's a new show so like it's not a new
show but it's a new they've changed a
lot of things with leah um
so like there were a couple fuck-ups
like this one guy he had like it was
like this american
the thing is is like it's a show about a
show because she's the star and she
becomes zigfield's girl and so they show
like the shows that she's acting in
in the show yeah and so one of them was
like this um american theme there's like
all these girlies dressed as like
soldiers it was so cute and like these
two guys were doing like this drill
dance with like these drill guns and
this guy just like [ __ ] the whole
thing up
but it's like i think it's because it's
like the arrangements are kind of new
they changed some things with leah so it
was by no means like completely void of
any error but she was and that was just
crazy to say
wow
so good
and now i really want to watch the movie
oh good
because it's like it's like a girl from
new york desperate to get famous like
biography
biography
you should watch the movie and report
back i'm going to and i'm glad that my
first time seeing it with lee was with
leah because like it needed to happen
and she'll always be fanny to you like
she is barbara will be to you what leah
is to other people like the secondary
fanny 100
it's the same way where like lady gaga
is to me what barbra streisand is to
other people from a star is born it's
just like generational oh my god
speaking of a star is born it's really
so crazy i read priscilla presley's book
and like elvis was supposed to
play norman maine at
opposite barbara and who ended up
playing him
like
chris christopherson i don't know i
think hold on let me just google that i
don't know why that name just came to
mind i actually think i watched that one
after the lady gaga when i went like on
a rabbit hole rabbit hole i watched the
judy garland one which was so cute
and i think i no i started the barber
one and i couldn't get past like the
first 10 minutes no offense
okay
it is
chris chris jefferson yeah
very good yeah uh
not that i know who that is even i would
love to know though like what barbara
thinks of lea michelle because you know
there are so many
people like just say that barbara hates
lily michelle um
and that's possible
but um i don't know how barbara can't
respect talent like for real
i feel like it's probably a mutually
respectful relationship but a little
adversarial because it's like you never
are gonna love someone who everyone is
saying is the new you that's always
gonna sting a little bit yeah that's
true that's true but i feel like
barbara's like a gracious aging queen no
yeah but still it's like i think that
just stings like imagine if there's like
a new podcast doing what we do and
everyone's like they're the new jackie
and claudia i'd be like
uh
death to them
are people saying that about someone no
i've never heard that before but i'm
sure like i mean if there's a podcast
that can do what we do welcome yeah no
that's the thing about being in a league
of your own
um but yeah i think it stings
no for sure um in the vogue article they
were like sneaky they trying to ask if
she heard from you know any fa past
fannies
which obviously includes beanie as well
because we're all just beyond curious um
and she was like yeah i have heard from
some like she didn't like give us
anything yeah wow it's literally there
was a barbra streisand tribute a bunch
of years ago and lee michelle did a
gorgeous rendition of my man
um
and barbara seemed to be enjoying it on
the telecast i go back and watch the
performance like once a year i'm sure
she was i'm just sure there's just like
a little something
like yeah a little nefariousness yeah
how could there not be human nature plus
they're both like diva stars so it's not
just like two ordinary people who are
being compared to each other it's like
the ego the pride okay two things one
going off of what you just said it's
very clear to me because i've now just
been consumed by lea michelle content of
her at the stage door you know
interviews things like that it's very
clear that she's been extremely humbled
and like that diva energy she had um
she has gotten rid of completely like
even when she was doing her bowels she
like did not want to bow alone she was
blowing kisses to everyone she was
bringing everyone up with her like she's
i don't think it's an act i think she
was like severely humbled by her scandal
and like being called out for being like
a menace to work with um so you'd love
to see that
and there are rumors rumors so there's
none no verification there are rumors
that um on the first night and i don't
know if this is something they're gonna
do every night but at least they did on
the first night there was an empty chair
in the um audience for cory monteith
because in glee um
she
spoiler alert gets cast as um fanny
bryce and it's after finn has passed and
they leave a seat empty for him oh my
god i have chills no i know i know i'm
not gonna cry so i that's just what like
a lot of like the fandom is saying on
tick tock there's absolutely no
verification if that's true but people
did report seeing an empty seat next to
jonathan groff
where like he would have been sitting um
i'm literally gonna cry um
so i don't know if that's true but
that's really sweet i know i hope it's
true like even if it's not true i just
think you know the folklore of it it's
nice the folklore of it yes
yes
um
so that's my review you absolutely have
to see it if you have the opportunity
people were flying in from all over like
it was literally like the place to be
they should do funny girl live for
christmas oh
free idea totally more because people
need yeah need to see it or it's like a
dear evan hansen thing where they make
it into a movie they'll do a remake of
the movie oh they could do that they
could do that but that takes like so
much more
time energy resources as opposed to like
give us a live sound stage have the cast
do their thing obviously you have to
change it a little bit but um that can
be nice we haven't heard what the
christmas live movie is going to be have
we no and we're getting close i feel
like this time last year we're already
hyped for annie live oh
i'm missing that time
can i tell you that's a hard knock life
it is a hard knock life
can i tell you oh that last night before
i was when while i was getting ready i
was doing an instagram live because i
like was so antsy i was like i need to
do something i'm literally just sitting
here waiting to go
and the way that the toasters were
playing with me last night okay so i got
up
and left the
the live for like a second and they like
came up with a plan
in the comments
to when i got back be like bestie check
instagram lee michelle escovid
how [ __ ] mean is that
and then they also came up with a plan
because the show was every night at
seven o'clock but on wednesdays is that
it's at eight o'clock because there's a
matinee so she does it two o'clock and
then at eight o'clock and everyone's
like claudia you're gonna be late at 6
30 the show's at seven i'm like wait
what
they're like yeah it's at seven like
what's wrong with you i'm like and ben
was one who told me eight so i had
reason to doubt it's not like i checked
it myself oh my god they were just like
[ __ ] playing with me on instagram
live it was not [ __ ] cool those are
some funny pranks though
yeah i know that was really good
i could respect the nature pretty well
thought out 100
i saw that you were live i was facetime
with olivia and then i was going to join
your live and you were wrapping up i i
think i was the last comment i said hey
oh you want to hear the craziest thing
right do you know who joined my life
who
samuel l jackson
he's followed me on instagram for years
it's just like a fun fact about me
um and it literally said samuel l
jackson has joined he might have just
like joined my accent and then swiped
away but i was talking to him for the
next 10 minutes i'm like sam what do you
think what i was going to say did you
call him out also that happens i
sometimes join someone's live and
immediately leave because like the live
comes up at the first story
or they used to send you push
notifications when someone would go live
so if you happen to click the
notification all of a sudden you're in
uh
that doesn't mean that you're there in
in
yeah so that was just like a weird time
for me
well that sounds lit
i'm so happy for you me too
and
how was your night my night was lovely
thank you very quiet i've been reading a
book uh historical fiction back to my
roots i think it's called the secret
life of violet skyler it's beatrice
williams who's like a christian hannah
like a girly premier historical fiction
author but i've never read one of her
solo books i read a book that she
co-authored with two other authors not
my favorite um but this one is really
really good so i'm really enjoying yeah
but um i've just been like eating
healthy you know when you feel like crap
the first few days when you're eating
healthy because you're like where's all
my carbs where's the sugar where's the
energy yeah yeah so i'm just like
you know
focused on that getting into it easing
into it but eating really healthy i've
been cooking a lot good so that's what's
new with me so exciting
so exciting and you're looking so cute
today ready to deliver the stories that
will tug at the heartstrings they will
um i don't know why i just opened my
jacket like that i'm sure i'm not gonna
like but i'm not gonna like what i see
that was weird that's like something
like people who like flash people on
this no no no no not that because you
were talking about my outfit so i was
like
i was giving a peek of my outfit but
like there's a reason why the jacket's
covering where's that jacket from good
american did you copy me because i've
had it for a year no i didn't i just
placed a big order at good american and
this is so plenty and so my style i also
placed like an enormous order at good
american and it's just been saving me
like every time i need something like oh
my god wait that order from good america
true and this little dress underneath is
also a good american
i am american wearing a seamless um you
can't see from your angle but everyone
else
can see
um good american like
is fabulous so fabulous always doing
new and better things i feel like
anytime i have a style idea in mind it's
like oh i want a romper that looks like
this or like a bodysuit that looks like
that or a tank top whatever
it's not good american
yeah and they also just like i really
cannot stress enough like how much i
love their the way their sizing is like
yeah
the obviously like the range of it but
also it's not like small medium large
like they created their own sizing and
it's just it's divine yeah did you get
the matching pants to this
jacket no i'm not a corduroy pant girl i
know i did it they don't fit yet but
but i feel like when they do
it gonna be really cute yeah okay yeah
no i saw the pants and i said no thank
you yeah no i i i hope that i could be
that girl maybe i won't be but it's
worth a shot that's the thing with
online shopping is that you sometimes
forget who you are um and you're like
yeah like i could wear these low-rise
khakis no i really don't like i feel
like i'm always getting i know what i do
i know my silhouette like i know what
cuts work for me like i'll never be
someone who wears a v-neck that's just
something weird about me
um
a lot i i know what works for me but
sometimes i'm like maybe that could be
my new thing if i just expand my mind
what if i just tried this new thing what
if i just
speaking no not speaking of before we
dive into the fast five jackie and i
released a
video episode and an audio episode uh we
recorded both for the patreon we a
couple weeks ago no maybe a couple
months ago we did a patreon episode that
people loved where we were just testing
our general history knowledge because
some one of us is smart and one of us is
not and it led us down this path because
we wanted to do a similar episode jackie
had the great idea to see if we could
pass the american immigration test you
know when you want to become a citizen
you have to learn about american history
and it's like low-key kind of a hard
test so we took the test we did like
these mock tests um and it was the
funniest episode and if you want to find
out if colleen hoover wrote the
declaration of independence head to
patreon.com morning toast if you want to
watch it as a vlog episode you can if
you want to watch it as a podcast
episode listen to it as a podcast
episode we released both for you guys
and it was just really like a really
great time it really was it's such a
great episode and i think that if you
are studying for your citizenship test i
don't think it's not helpful
agreed i think there's a lot to be
learned in there like some funny jokes
that will help you remember
the answers
right right like ben franklin and his
little glasses like what is ben franklin
remember for now do you remember do you
remember like one thing that he was from
yes being a writer girl
what did he what did he write
do you even know i don't remember either
okay but here's another one
uh
what was it name one of the people who
wrote the declaration no no not wrote
federalist papers name one of the people
john jay
publius
publius also i finally found out who we
were fighting
in world war ii besides germany who were
we fighting in world war ii
germany japan and italy
which honestly if you had given me a
thousand guesses i never would have
chosen those three like japan and italy
like feel like just no italy
specifically feels like so irrelevant to
world history okay but just think about
mussolini
nefariously for sure for sure various we
fought him so if you want to learn
giggle and hang out with your girly
girls patreon.com slash the morning
toast yeah it was really good stuff
so now without further ado to do and yes
brew is feeling so much better thank you
everyone
for the well wishes it meant a lot to
him he took it easy yesterday a lot of
time with eating pad i made him a couple
bowls of soup and crackers and
he's doing much better thank you
thank you so now without further
do here are the past five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
today's episode is brought to you by
visa do you ever dream of starting
something game changing well visa can
help make it happen maybe it's creating
and selling your own customized sneakers
for cats or transforming your dorm into
a plushy pop-up shop or finally going
mainstream with your streaming side
hustle uh or starting a world premiere
morning show podcast network
sparkling cocktail beverage whatever
um
well that's why you've got to check out
visa whatever you're bold enough to try
visa has the power to help bring your
game changing ideas to life visa anyone
can change the game today's episode is
also brought to you by fashion pass we
know so many toasters already know about
and love fashion pass because it is the
tr it is truly the senior clothing
rental service where you're getting
unlimited rentals for one flat price the
best part of fashion pass when you
compare it to other rental services is
like the clothes that's literally all
that matters is the clothes and
sometimes on these sites all you're
getting is grandma clothing grandma ugly
clothing that is was in style 45 years
ago but fashion pass they have stuff on
their website that is literally
on sale right now at some of your
favorite websites they carry sickening
brands like
for love and lemons free people show me
your moomoo oh my shirt is from show me
your movement we've been talking about
muumuu a lot recently um
and you're saving so much money on
clothes because you're not buying all
the time um
where you would normally spend 200 on an
outfit that you're gonna wear on
vacation literally one time after you
get your photo clothing rental is
so affordable and it's just so much
better for everyone so they have
different plans we we are on the
trendsetter plan where you get to pick
three clothing items and two accessories
for every time you order and you can
switch out your items as many times a
month as you want so you don't have to
wait a certain amount of time to switch
out
it couldn't be easier and the best part
is that if you want to buy something
that you rent because you love it so
much you can get a huge discount
anywhere between 30 and 60 off we have a
special discount code for you guys it's
fashionpass.com use code toast at
checkout to get 40 off your first month
so you can try it for just 39
that's unlimited rentals for just 39
with code toast at fashionpass.com thank
you claudia
it's a pleasure
doing business with you
[Music]
just stalling as much as possible i know
um dragging your feet because i don't
want to report the first story which is
that queen elizabeth is under medical
supervision as doctors are concerned for
her health the palace says
queen elizabeth's health is causing
concern for her doctors buckingham
palace said in a statement on thursday
quote following further evaluation this
morning the queen's doctors are
concerned for her majesty's health and
have recommended she remain under
medical supervision the queen remains
comfortable and at balmoral
their royal highnesses the prince of
wales and the duchess of cornwall have
traveled to balmoral buckingham palace
said adding that prince william is also
making his way to balmoral from his home
in windsor so all of the queen's kids
are going to be with her william is on
his way kate and
her family the kids just started
grandkids just started school yesterday
so she's not going yet which i feel like
if it was really
serious like
the the end they would be there that's
true so that gives me a little hope i
know megan and harry were also in the uk
and they cancelled something that they
had and they're going to to bow moral
to be with the queen
so
you know as a rational human being i
think we all need to just like you know
come to grips with the fact that like
sooner or later there will be a time
where the queen is no longer with us yes
um and every time we get one of these
little health scares you know that
impending doom just gets closer and
closer
and
i don't know if this is going to be the
time i pray that it's not i think she
is an invaluable world leader an
incredible monarch
um a wonderful grandmother grandmother
mother and friend and great-grandmother
and great-grandmother um
but the possibility of you know this
happening soon is is real yeah
she's a 96 so when it's a you know
seeking medical attention even if it's
for a cut on her finger when you're at
that age you always take it seriously
yeah
for sure this seems more serious though
than in the past i i don't know why
yeah well it's cause like everyone
dropped everything to go and they'd like
put out a statement she's at balmoral
but i'm holding on because the grand
campers are not there
right
and like balmoral is like her favorite
place yeah it's
it's it's personal to her i feel like
when she's at buckingham palace it's
more work that's where she goes to you
know
be with herself
but you know and i was thinking about
this this morning you know of course
there will be a time when charles
succeeds
and charles in charge and then charles
in charge um and then william is the
successor and it'll be like an official
changing of the guards prince philip and
and the queen
will no longer be here um and it does
make me just think about how harry and
megan i think really the one and only
tie they have to this family is with
queenie um and that's a pretty big tie
because she's the [ __ ] queen
but i think after she's gone
i don't think they'll be welcome at
events and stuff like
it's very clear him and william don't
get along and i don't think him and
charles get along
yeah
like so then being in the uk and just
hopping over to baltimore like that
won't happen no they're gonna be like
not losing their press passes their
credentials
and even though they've kind of you know
publicly
turned their back on the family they've
still like always been like kissing
queenie's ass like yeah naming the
daughter lillabet every time it's an
interview we were on zoom with grand
like they want everyone to know that all
is good with grand gran is not nefarious
grant has never acted nefarious it
wasn't grand who said the thing about
archie
so that is like their last
i think tie to the family but it's it's
one that keeps them in the fold because
she's a queen it's not like you know
it's not like it's edward no whatever
the queen says goes right she's like
it's like the only the best tie you can
have yeah
it's very sad
it is
and you you know
do you think you'll cry if and when
maybe
like there will be probably a lot of um
tributes tributes the everything will be
televised
it could happen
yeah it's just
beyond the would be i like i even hate
talking like this but you know
no one lives forever
it will be
the real end of an era
yeah because she is from like the last
generation of great monarchs yeah
and we'll ne i don't think there will
ever be a monarch who will reign as long
as she has
she's and be as admired and universally
respected like even if you're not a
monarchist like and you live in the uk i
still think you have enormous respect
for the queen right
so
and when you think about like the fact
that she's been alive for 96 years like
in all that she's she's seen seen she
lived through the holocaust
right yeah world war ii
right because like loki her husband had
some like nazi vibes but no he didn't he
had some ties oh he didn't his family
didn't
okay but he did not
no his family did
he fought the nazis
oh that was gracious of him yeah he was
in the war
after all his family did he was in the
war
okay that changes things for sure i tell
you this every time and you continue to
sully his memory with this crap
speaking of
prince philip
did you see that
like picture from next week's episode of
game of thrones
where damon's hair is cut
i didn't see that his hair was cut but i
oh i didn't see a picture i watched a
preview though what happens next week i
don't know i don't watch the previews
because i feel like they're full of
spoilers um but the picture of him
without hair is going viral on tick tock
i mean on twitter and i just feel like
he's samson like i don't think i'll be
attracted to him without his hair to be
completely honest then he goes back to
being prince philip
yes and i didn't even like look at him
twice when he was prince philip yeah i
mean either but also because that was
during prince philip's like bill and era
yeah that's true that's true [ __ ] boy
ballerina era fuckboy ballerina not like
i'm gonna be the man my wife needs to me
to be era and i'm gonna be the gran and
maybe the great gran not like i'm gonna
be the man this country needs you to be
yeah oh you know what was cool
when i was in turks and caicos and we
were at the airport when you got out of
security there was a portrait of the
queen
so they're part of the commonwealth
right yeah and i was like trying to
explain to ben and margo like what that
means but it's tough one to explain
something when you don't know what it
means totally um because ben was like so
like she's in charge i'm like no
no it's just like a part of the
commonwealth they like recognize her and
they like have her face on the money
yeah and probably probably a few other
ties too but
it's like they're
it's like they're one big family they
see and those are some distant cousins
right
that's what i think but it's like in
that family
the cousins don't make decisions for
your personal family right it was just
confusing because like that also
happened to me in the airport in the
british virgin islands but it's like
british virgin islands so it's literally
britain it was less for you to wrap your
head around right
right and i was a two and a half flight
hour flight from new york so i'm like
it's literally like a 30 minute flight
to miami so i'm like how is this britain
right i'm in britain it's what up grand
grand brain
hello brother
graham it's me
let me into the castle
that's harry today we're sending our
best wishes to balmoral today we really
like
beyond we're just making light because
you know it's difficult for us to to
discuss
it is
and the queen is
she is lightness you know
the queen is coming
that was literally my first introduction
to asmr
because she's literally like the queen
like it's like perfection it's like
triggers on your ears
the queen is coming and then the second
one was
julie
julie
yeah
and then my third one was josie b asmr
my queen
yes you're absolute queen she gave me a
facial before bed last night and it was
so nice
you're wild
wild
are you ready for our next story was
probably equally as important as this
news about the queen what is it
the dancing with the stars season 31
cast has been announced plus partners
oh i don't like care about the partners
there are people who like wait with
baited breath with their t-shirts on
like who is glenn going to be with like
there's only thing that i care about the
partners is like there's always one
eligible female or male yeah paired with
an eligible single female or male and
it's like oh
perhaps what if they just
started dating yeah okay so first we
have selma blair and sasha farber
that i by the way i was just on tick
tock selma blair has a beauty line
that's made it's like um it's made she
has uh ms right yeah so it's like meant
to help people who have um
who are like limited in their mobility
and it was like so different i never saw
any makeup like it before and she was
like putting on mascara with like this
applicator and it looked like so good
that's awesome yeah i thought it was so
cool i love selma blair yeah it's cool
that she's doing it honestly this season
cast there's a lot of more traditional
celebrities
not this next person um charlie theresa
judice and pasha they love reality tv
stars and i think she'll be great i
think she'll last five minutes she'll be
great in the sense that like
she'll
be good for the show going home yeah
yeah no but like they love
like that's a perfect casting dancing
with the stars then also gabby wendy and
val chernkowski she is one of the new
bachelorettes i think
i think they're season ended not sure
next vinnie guadagnino
and koko iwasaki he's going to be great
by the way being surprised he hasn't
done it sooner
he also has like a residency in vegas
with the chip and dale so like he's a
dancer like he's pretty coordinated i
think he'll be great and i think this
would be great for his star like i think
people forget about how funny and kind
and like charismatic he is no i think
they're gonna love him i think he could
win i think so too there's a lot of
really
charlie's gonna win people who could win
jordan sparks and brandon armstrong
jesse james decker and alan bersten she
could win
yeah
she could shangela and gleb
shangela
oh my god
i told you this is like a
so far there i don't know how many we've
done but we're like eight four eight on
real solid and they're finally like
moving into i don't think there's ever
been a drag queen on
i think that uh
this is the first time
that's huge and shangela's iconic yeah
oh my god then cheryl ladd and louie
she is an actress she was from charlie's
angels uh back in the day always got to
throw an old timer in there
yes you do then jason lewis who is uh
smith jared and peta
wait
peter first of all sorry um
what smith jared well why is he on
dancing with the stars and like not the
sex and the city reboot like
i don't know
that's kind of weird i'm actually like
gonna watch like not me literally being
obsessed with this cast keep going uh
joseph bana and daniella
he's a fitness model who's the son of
arnold schwarzenegger and mildred bana
then trevor donovan and emma trevor
donovan from 90210 you'd recognize this
face anywhere
who does he play
he plays teddy
the lgbtq
character
teddy montgomery
i like the way he just said that lgbt
little melody to it lgbtq character i'm
i'm reading all of his accomplishments
but you don't know that yes you do
claudia let me zoom in further he also
is a hallmark man
these days you know him oh for sure
for sure blondini blondini yeah then
daniel durant and brit stewart he's from
coda
okay wayne brady and whitney carson
that's going to be a really good duo
sam champion and cheryl burke he's a
weatherman
oh cute charlie demilio and mark ballas
and heidi dimiglio and artem like
charlie dimelio being on not only is a
person who's like the most famous with
the most followers and the most
background in dancing like it's not even
fair
no it's not fair she's going to win like
and then if she doesn't when it's like
well then the show's a rig because she
has most fans and she's a really good
she's getting the highest scores highest
scores and highest votes
so it makes no sense
but do you want to just place your
prediction for who's going to win i
actually don't think charlie's going to
win
you don't no it's just too obvious and i
think that like
i don't know if her fan base watches
dancing with the stars
i think charlie's gonna win even though
like
last night you would have thought jojo
was gonna win but iman jumper won
yeah
so okay that's fair i'm going to go with
um
vinnie guadagnino i was going to go with
vinnie too
and i'll be rooting for him i love him
the first podcast i ever did was vinnie
guadagnino's before podcasting was a
thing and i was like what is this like
janky ass fake radio show and she
introduced me to podcasting do you think
it's easier for a man to win or a woman
to win man because in like traditional
ballroom dancing like the woman is the
star of the dance usually so if the
woman is a pro
it's easier for you to just like blend
it easier for it to look good so i think
you can pass for longer as a man but i
think it's harder to dazzle and i think
like the winner needs to dazzle so i
actually
i think more often women win i think so
too but
no that's interesting i don't know
sound off in the comments
yeah okay this next story is so
salacious like a little is it so
salacious that it has to be brought to
you by third love
yes
so third love is
everything of the sword they have the
number one best-selling bras that form
to your body and make your boobs look
your best they have straps that don't
slip there's no pinching or digging if
you have been looking for a new bra that
isn't just like
a third
no not a third that isn't just like an
extra limb
it's so tough and it's probably because
you're wearing the wrong size and that's
why you've got to go to third love
because what's so great about their love
not only is there they're amazing bras
undies sleepwear but it's their fit
finder quiz so you'll basically take
their fit their fitting room quiz that
makes it super easy to find your bra
size because it's very likely that you
have not been wearing the right bra size
as i wasn't up until two years ago until
i literally took the fitting room quiz
at third love
so it's like a personal shopper they're
gonna ask you questions about size
breast shape current fit issues
and then your style
choices to help find a bra that's
perfect for you they also have a love
your fit guaranteed so if it's not
if you're not loving it you can get an
exchange or a return for free for 60
days and their team of expert fit
stylists are available to answer all
your questions feeling is believing and
give your boobs a 20 24 7 comfort and
support that you deserve upgrade your
bra today and get 20 off your first
order at thirdlove.com toast that's 20
off at thirdlove.com
toast third love is really one of the
best sponsors we have here at the toast
jackie and i are a couple of big-titted
ladies and it's not so easy for us no
not at all it's really not
okay our next story a little salacious
tabloid gossip
that has me really shook so the founder
of rolling stone jan wenner has written
a memoir and he has some
shocking celebrity factoids but none
more shocking than him confirming that
confirming that angelina jolie was
behind the famous brad pitt pictures so
in adventures
here's the story
in addition to rolling stone wenner
owned us weekly for a time he writes how
in 2005 a photographer that us worked
with received a tip that angelina jolie
was staying at a resort on the coast of
africa with brad pitt who was still
married to jennifer aniston at the time
the new couple who had worked together
on the movie mr and mrs smith had
generated plenty of rumors that they
were also an off-screen couple but
nothing had been confirmed but the
photographer was told not only where the
pair were staying but also given details
about the time of their daily walk along
with the suggestion of where they could
be secretly photographed
he said we got the photo we got the
proof we had the worldwide scoop the
debut of brangelina he said this wait
sorry was i always forget was brad pitt
married to jennifer aniston yes
wow that's like so crazy i always
thought they were like boyfriend
girlfriend he said the tipster was
angelina
that is crazy
yeah
when they see uh yeah i think so there's
a bunch of like juicy factoids in this
article but this is for our purposes
like the juices
when they say that celebrities are
always call the paparazzi on themselves
i'm like yeah you know when they go to
the gas station when they're like
feeling their look but like but i'm like
these pictures that are taken like on a
vacation that are like so anyone would
kill for these pictures like
they would definitely stalk down brad
and angelina get a picture of them
together like those are not staged no
and you always think like yes every
celebrity calls a paparazzi on
themselves but not like brad pitt
angelina jolie level no but not when
like you're
when you're that level and like you
have something like this like this i
feel like this is what paparazzi is for
they're getting the scoop like they're
going out into the uh and
hiding in the bushes and like
it's like no
she called them no but like
yes
see the thing is it's like it's really
tough to know which it is which is how
like celebrities are kind of given like
a level of
skepticism on whether or not they call
to themselves because in jeanette
mccurdy's book she's in hawaii on the
beach with her man and she lied to her
mom about where she was and the
paparazzi took a picture of her and her
mom literally wrote her an email like
[ __ ] disowning her
calling her a [ __ ] for being 18 like
and having a boyfriend oh my god she
didn't even know that she had a
boyfriend and so like and jeanette like
it ruined her whole trip she stayed
inside in the room though for the rest
of the time like having anxiety her
boyfriend had to lock her phone in the
safe right and they so i do feel like
there are so many times when no when
it's the paparazzi are doing their job
they're getting a scoop uh i would have
thought that something like this is
exactly
that
well you know it makes sense why
angelina had a lot to gain by that being
out there because now everyone knows jen
knows and they can be together like it's
not like a secret anymore yeah
damn the more i learned about angelina
jolie the more miserable she sounds like
there's you know a lot of stuff coming
out because of her divorce and the rad
thing and i think brad was definitely
toxic too like especially struggled with
his drinking and could potentially have
been like a little bit nuts
um but she sounds like miserable too
yeah
there is a lot coming out i haven't been
able to
keep track of all of it something about
a winery
yeah well they own this like [ __ ]
chateau
winery and it's become like a huge asset
in their divorce they both want it
yeah and i'm sure if i like went down
the rabbit hole
you know what nevermind i'm not gonna
say that okay
anyways i just feel like that's a bit of
hot goss no that's like that's [ __ ]
crazy
was there any other like good bombshells
from the book not bombshells but he has
like a lot of
funny anecdotes about his uh
experiences with certain celebrities
like tom cruise bette midler
arnold schwarzenegger nothing like no t
just like he just this way and he was
like saying how tom cruise like seems
really guarded and like you can have a
cool conversation with him and feel like
you like are bonding and then you
actually walk away being like i know
nothing about this person well that is
like a telltale sign of like a [ __ ]
serial killer like people who are so
manipulative like con men only ask about
you you know
and like the second that they
like the question turn like ask me a
question
claudia how was funny girl last night
oh it was great you you actually have
you seen funny girl you remind me so
much of fanny
like it's like that switching like it's
[ __ ] manipulative yeah
i never heard that
yeah
okay well sounds like a great book i
have a lot on my content plate so if any
of you want to read it and let me know
if there are more interesting factoids
sound off in the comments
sound off in the comments
s o i
t c
oh happy national literacy day by the
way is benton doing okay
you know he i woke up this morning and
he was gone
is that why ben loves leah michelle did
i already make this joke
i don't know it sounds like kind of
familiar yeah
no ben had to get out of dodge like he's
literally on a plane to vegas right now
like some days are just you need to take
a personal day could be like the
anniversary of something like
national holiday it's just not for you
he's on a work trip he's going actually
have you ever been to lake tahoe
no
no i'm like so jealous but it's like for
work but still like
but still that's a pretty cool place to
go it's [ __ ] hard to get to though
yeah i feel like it's like the hamptons
of l.a l.a so true even though i feel
like there's 500 places like that like
malibu is also the hamptons of l.a so
in the sense of it's hard to get to
i feel like santa barbara's the hamptons
of l.a but is is there not like a santa
barbara municipal airport
municipal uh i mean if you have a
private jet it's easy to get anywhere
it's true no you drive i think it's like
a two oh no palm springs is the hamptons
of l.a but they have an airport they
have so many options it's not even fair
it's so not fair
darn dark i mean i guess we have like
newport
we have
the jersey shore hamptons
upstate
i feel like there's another like
one by newport nantucket nantucket yeah
we have a few we have nantucket we'll
always have nantucket always
are you ready for our next story is it
fifth and final yet no
not even
ansel elgort is sharing photos from his
italian vacation with shailene woodley i
know i saw it on my
ansel instagram and shailene woodley are
enjoying their summer adventure together
overseas on wednesday ansel shared a
carousel of images on instagram from his
tour in italy featuring his longtime
friend and co-star from 2014's fault in
our stars he said it's the time for the
season of loving hearts okay like seeing
these two together obviously brought me
back to that film and it reminded me
that like i saw that movie in theaters i
believe with margo ashrae um
and the way that like people were
audibly sobbing like like the theater
sounded like this
that me and margo could not stop [ __ ]
laughing and i think people thought that
we were crying too when we just like let
them it was beyond like it was literally
like teenage mental illness the way
people were like oh and so ah
like it was not okay
that's not okay i've never seen the
movie obviously when you see a picture
like this of two people
it sparks relationship rumors but i i do
think these two are just friends me too
reconnecting i think like
shailene woodley like is meant to be
with aaron rodgers like it will happen
like i'm not like i haven't gotten off
the ship like
i'm gonna die of dysentery on the ship
because i'm not getting off and there's
no food or water not getting off also
has ansel broken up with his longtime
lady live yes
when did that happen like they were on
off on off and then like nobody cared
anymore and i guess they're off you know
like that's how it happened got it so i
think this is just two friends
yeah being friendly
and the whole ansel thing is like so
weird yeah
it's like we're like we're all just
moving on question mark
i don't think so i don't think so either
like does the article mention it
oh that's a great question they're
smiling at a restaurant this is people
magazine last slide oh however it seems
at some point during the vacation things
got a little wild and one of the snaps
he poses naked by a pool just a towel to
cover his private parts
no they also did the iconic move from
dirty dancing
um
not one nary a mention
see i just find that interesting because
um you literally cannot read like
anything about lea michelle and funny
girl without hearing about the fact that
like her ex-co-worker said she was mean
um and it's like everywhere and like
ansel elgort was literally accused of
rape
rape right and it's not even in the
article like that's crazy that's crazy
like not to literally make everything
about me but like any time i've ever
been written up it's like and 300 years
ago claudia said something like gross on
twitter like but
yeah
no that's so weird i wonder what that is
it's either like a certain publicist
yeah relationship
there's some back channel thing
happening there where it's like we're
gonna move forward with ansel we're not
gonna mention this stuff anymore and
you're gonna get on board right now it's
like it's like you either get approved
or you don't like until he's been
approved right either like whatever your
scandal was no matter how big or small
either it sticks with you forever or
never again as it mentioned yeah and i'm
feeling like we're moving in that way
with ansel we are really [ __ ] weird
and i also feel like
all of us are
inadvertently like
peddling whatever going along with going
along with whatever they say like if
it's lea michelle i mean for you it's
like lea michelle will always be like
your queen and that supersedes her
scandal but it could be anyone where
it's like it always gets mentioned or
it's a distant memory no it's so weird
and it's so important to note like the
different degrees of scandal like right
leah michelle was accused by a lot of
her castmates a lot of them being black
i was like of of being micro-aggressive
and then a lot of our other cancer
candidates it's just being a [ __ ]
wench
and uh the other person here ansel
elgort is literally accused of like a
crime yeah
so i just find it interesting that's
that's all i'm gonna say yeah it is
interesting but i just think we can't
control you know what the media is doing
but we can control what we're doing so i
think our participation we
just need to have that same energy and
decide you know is that something or do
you always want to bring up someone's
scandal or not does it depend on the
level it just feels like it's so weird
not to it's like it's not like it's a
little thing like yeah all right
somebody with old tweets like you're not
gonna find me bringing it up every time
i'm talking about them because honestly
i don't [ __ ] care and i just i'm not
one of those losers who thinks it's
indicative of who they are as a person
like i am a normal human being who
believes in growth right um
but like rape is a little different i
agree
and that's just a little bit about me
yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
so soon
so soon
only if it's the fifth and final story
that's brought to you by all birds
it is i love my all birds the days are
long and they are hot
so that means there's more opportunities
to get outside and make the most of
after work happy hours impromptu picnics
you know what summer needs a shoe that's
up for anything and that's why the tree
breezer flat from all birds is
breathable super supportive and it can
keep you comfortable from morning to
night
so the tree breezer is a ready for
anything flat that's made from
breathable tree materials eucalyptus
fiber is moisture wicking it is odor
reducing and it is perfect for hot days
or if you're just a girly who's prone to
moisture in her shoe like some of us had
to put like spray in our shoes growing
up like some of us are just like we have
these problems
um
and the tree breezer is great because
the ribbed collar is movement friendly
so they're super super comfortable and
it feels like the the shoe was literally
designed for your foot and they're so
easy to clean you can throw them in the
washing machine air dry it for the
perfect refresh the fact that like their
shoes that you can throw in the washing
machine is so revolutionary like i'm mad
i didn't invent it myself um if you want
lightweight breathable and cushy all day
shoes the tree breezer is your secret to
a comfortable shoe find your perfect
pair at allbirds.com that's
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s dot-com find your
perfect pair at allbirds.com today
great thank you claudia
thank you so much i'm just like i'm
checking my phone to make sure there's
no updates on queen elizabeth and
there's literally like people with their
hoax tweets like they're so annoying
yeah
but we're it's
quiet else quiet all good all good all
good okay our fit and final story real
housewives of beverly hills star diana
jenkins donates a hundred thousand
dollars to tom girardi's alleged victims
real housewives of beverly hills star
diana jenkins announced on wednesday
that she made a 100 000 donation to the
alleged victims of tom girardi her
co-star erica jane's estranged husband
who was in legal hot water the wealthy
philanthropist claimed in a post on
instagram that she was not aware
of the 2018 lion air 610 flight tragedy
until it became a topic of conversation
on beverly hills she recently became a
full-time cast member she said i feel so
much sympathy for the widows and orphans
left behind i know firsthand the pain
that and suffering that accompanies the
loss of a family member having lost my
brother in the closing days of the
bosnian war i want to do what i can to
support those people who suffered so
much
see i thought this was so interesting
because i truly just cannot tell if
she's doing this like
to make erica look bad or to support her
as a friend because they're like really
good friends they took a trip her rena
and diana um to hawaii like after
filming like they're good friends so
erica commented on the post like a bunch
of hearts
okay but then i think some of the other
cast members feel like perhaps it makes
them look bad because
they didn't do that
and if any of them like have supported i
don't know it's it's weird the erica
part
but it's like oh i just found this out
and i'm going to donate to the victims
as opposed to like
the other women who
like it for years and it never occurred
to them to check the gofundme but i per
is there a gofundme no i don't know and
it's not on these random women to cook
from girardi right
but at the end of the day like charities
charity and they all have like a ton of
money like a hundred thousand dollars to
kyle richards is not a lot
yeah it's it's an interesting move and
i'm not caught up on beverly hills i do
want to get caught up especially since
now they're apparently in aspen which is
when things start to happen and it's
like a big fight between kathy and lisa
arena and apparently it's all about
8-1-8 tequila i'm so behind i wanted to
catch up yesterday i have two episodes
we'll do i'll do a full recap tomorrow i
will be catching up today i'm really
sorry i said i would get back on track
and i didn't okay i'm so curious that
818 i don't even know if i could catch
up at this point but maybe i'll try
uh
and so diana i feel like she's really
the villain and she seems to be really
like scary and mean yeah but then she
does something like this and it's like
no see like she's been so villainized
like i have to assume she has ulterior
motives of course which is so [ __ ] up
like maybe she just wants to help people
right
like she's more money than god a hundred
thousand dollars to her is seriously
twenty dollars to us
yeah yeah
so that's why i have to watch because i
don't know
yeah you can't like you need to get a
read on her and i'll try to read on her
she's literally [ __ ] evil like she's
evil so this is
i don't know at the end of the day
a hundred thousand dollars no matter
your motives is gonna go help people so
that's always great but what does this
mean for the overall story the plot the
plot thickens it's what it does again
it's very thick just like may thick
um so those were the fast five and they
were quite good truly like yeah i know
you needed to know a bust you definitely
needed to know them tomorrow is our
final episode of the week it's going to
be friday so we're going to be just
girly girl chatting on a friday so we're
just going to have such great energy we
are are you doing anything tonight
no i'm so tired i
have uh meetings meetings meetings
podcast podcast podcast this has been
like such a crazy busy week yeah um
and i'm gonna catch up on beverly hills
tonight so i can do an amazing show for
everyone tomorrow and hopefully i'll be
uh catching the new episode of southern
charm tonight okay play my schedule
giving up on southern charm i love it so
much even a bad episode like i just love
it i don't know why
yeah i i can't and now with paige down
there like bringing her new york energy
i feel like a lot of people are not
feeling her on this season
but i am and i always
but what's the thing about southern
charm is like two people could be
fighting and it's like well i love both
of these people so right it's like but
it doesn't it doesn't hurt me to i don't
know it's just like it's like paige and
naomi were beefing but i love them both
and they actually reach resolution
catherine and naomi have so much beef
catherine is out of control but like
there's something about her presence on
the show i'm always going to root for
her
yeah because that's like
because she's been through a lot on the
show yes yes but at some point like we
are all adults who have been through
things and you have to start acting
right yeah yeah yeah
so that's our show thank you guys so
much for listening and we'll see you
tomorrow for friday so thank you so much
for listening to the morning tell us the
monday morning show where we deliver the
house stories that you need to know
every monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so spotify action central
public radio io radio catapults all the
places where we listen to the podcast
find us the morning toast live story
about how beautiful stunning and spar we
are have an amazing thursday we'll see
you tomorrow for
friday friday gotta get down on friday
love ya bye